and his brethren went to feed their
father's flock and shechem so they took
off and Israel said unto Joseph do you
not thy brethren feed the flock and
Shechem come and I will send thee unto
Him and he said to him and he said to
him here up here am I and when they saw
him afar off even before he came near
unto them they conspired against him to
slay him rough people back then right
this is this sort of thing is happening
quite frequently and they said to one
another
behold the dreamer cometh come now
therefore let us slay him cast him into
some pit and we will say some evil beast
hath devoured him and we shall see what
becomes of his dreams so there's an echo
of the cain and abel story there
obviously you know I mean it's not quite
as clear because in the cain and abel
story abel is clearly just doing well
and here you can't quite get a handle on
joseph's character you can't tell if he
is actually the elect or if he's just a
spoiled brat with delusions of grandeur
you know and but it doesn't matter
because his brothers are so irritated at
his the fact that he's favored and
perhaps even the fact that he might be
someone destined for for something
special that they find it perfectly
reasonable to destroy that and it's so
hard so interesting how often that motif
of pulling down an ideal manifests
itself in these old stories right it's
it's the pattern is established in the
Cain and Abel story it just repeats and
repeats and repeats and I I think that's
dead true I think it just repeats all
the time so that people are annoyed
about how tragic their lives are they're
annoyed that they're subject to
malevolence and they're annoyed that
they're not doing as well as other
people are doing and that makes them
that puts them exactly into this state
of mind
now maybe with modern people if you're
gonna kill someone because you're
resentful as a modern person you don't
generally slay them and throw them into
a pit you know what you do is you just
kill them slowly over a few decades and
it isn't obvious to me that that's any
better so I've seen Plan
of married couples who were in that
situation it's like it's like yeah there
is this Mitch Hedberg
he used to complain about turtlenecks
hey so it was like being strangled by a
really weak midget and it's probably
really politically incorrect jokes but
it's a funny joke so and then you see
you see relationships that are like that
it's like each person has their hands
around the neck of the other person but
they don't have enough courage to
actually to squeeze they just put enough
pressure on just cut the circulation off
a tiny bit so the person just gets like
they died over a 30-year period
something like that so yeah and you all
laughed because you know it's true
that's why